when you find a tree that has an apple
and just discovering new varieties it's
just I mean I live for that
I'm Annie Brennan my wife and I we
around our town and we forage for wild
apples and we make it into a series of
ciders based on where the apples are
located
you saw the Gramercy Tavern yeah yeah
Gramercy Tavern which I've only not once
I know it's famous and especially their
wine menu is somewhat famous having
cider made from wild forage fruit is
really unusual
something that can only be done in very
small amounts what comes out of the
bottle is really special we go out into
the woods we go to places where apples
are not at all influenced by human
cultivation we're searching the woods
and sometimes it's difficult to find the
trees and if the light doesn't hit the
silver and the trunk just right you may
not even know it's an apple tree you're
in luck when you find not just one or
two but a whole forest of trees which
sometimes does exist
what I love is discovering varieties
that are just so peculiar you would
never find them in a grocery store the
other day we found an apple that has red
flesh you bite into it and it just looks
like a pomegranate they're telling us
process
takes about four hours to grind and
press enough juice to fill a barrel
think of those barrels as bears
hibernating nine months after you
collected the apples that's when it's
ready